Another thing Dr. Bright is not allowed to
do at the Foundation: Dr. Bright is Not Allowed
to Play "Hippocratic Oath Chicken" with the
Medical Staff!
The Hippocratic Oath is deeply important to
all medical professionals, including those
on staff at the SCP Foundation.
Dr. Bright is not permitted to try and convince
the medical staff to break the Hippocratic
Oath in any way.
He is especially not allowed to expose them
to potentially dangerous anomalies while taunting,
"Still want to do no harm?
You sure?"
It's a waste of time, resources, and it's
just plain rude.
One of these days, they're going to snap and
slap him across the face and not one of us
will stop them.